fashion which is on early diverse
selection Poppaea last one it's a talk
of swansea roskie on register automata
thank you very much Prakash answer thank
you very much for the invitation and
letting me speak here and so I would
like to tell you about a selection of
recent results concerning reach the
register and automata and they were
obtained in joint work with steven
ramsey and nikos alekos it's a
registered Thomas are and are a class of
atomic aah over infinite alphabets the
alphabet is now instead of being a
finite say that there's a countable sets
without really any structure so we just
use a quality and it's one of the sets
sets was mentioned in an equalizer and
Hawk so I'm going to take you through
some complexity results about visual
tamata although first I'll explain why
I'm really interested in in these things
so i picked results were it turns out
crucial to think about symmetries in
order to arrive at optimal bounds or at
least better balance then and there is
known known before so there are many
reasons why one might be interested in
automata over in fifth alphabets well it
could be a natural extension of the
standard formal language theory and
automate over infinity alphabets play an
important role in clarifying and the
peril of logics logics relevant to
database theory and also useful in and
able to drive XML and processing but I'm
coming from from a different and
erection namie namely programming
language semantics and they're such a
Tomata become useful when we want to
account for computational scenarios and
in which an unbounded number of
resources can be produced so here I'm
thinking about situations in which we
can create references
objects threads and and so on so the
semantics community has been working for
years on capturing and computation their
faithful way and notably thanks to game
semantics we now have a wide range of
models that that are perfect in some
sense so they are perfect in that they
can be claimed to capture the essence of
programs and well in a very concrete way
known as the full abstraction property
so a model is called fully abstract if
an equality of interpretations here and
coincides with well the associated
notion of program equivalence so here in
the fully abstract model we capture
mathematically what it means to programs
to be equivalent and once we construct
models of this kind of course we would
like to use them to reason about its
equivalent so this is our case after
constructing fleeing abstract game
models of the references objects and
similar and generative phenomena I
wanted to see what what can be done with
with these with these models in the
spirit of verification and we need it
automata theoretic techniques to support
representations of such models and okay
so and my talk will focus on languages
with with this generative phenomena in
an order to accounts for for them and a
new branch of game semantics emerged
recently called nominal game semantics
that the refinement off of the game
models you may have heard about gain
models from from the 90s they are
refined in order to account for
references objects and so on in a more
faithful way and in particular nominal
game semantics involves an infinite set
of names in
in the process of of playing games so
this internet sites and can be used
elements from this side can be used in
moves and and well of course the fact
that the set is infinite means that we
can we can model and resource resource
creation so here's a list of programming
languages thats that have been covered
by nominal game semantics starting from
simple languages that's just great names
and and and pass them and compare them
for a quality through languages that
have all kinds of storage mechanism so
for storing names for storing integer
references for storing high order
references so this is the language with
with exceptions and and finally we have
done we have arrived at a fragments of
Java code known as middleweight Java in
the literature there's the semantics
picture but in the talk and I would like
to focus on on using these models in
practice and here's an example of the
kind of thing that one would like to do
in the fully automated way and this
actually becomes possible thanks to this
marriage of nominal game semantics with
with a suitable automata theory so here
are two terms very simple ones taken
from the ML language so we have one term
here and the second one here and the
first one here creates a reference it's
a private reference will not be revealed
and that's why when and the environment
supplies and name to the program this
test will never succeed so the Alcan
will be false because or the assumption
is that the environment can Nevin can
never guess the private name so this is
this is consistent with what's going on
in languages such as Java or a
male so this term will do is it greets
references and so on is actually
equivalent to this term calculating the
constant function false and well we can
convince ourselves that actually these
these two terms are equivalent by
working out they gain semantically
notations of these terms and they will
look like this and game semantics plays
our exchanges of moves between two
players so these players corresponds to
the environment this is the context
that's that will be interested in using
and the program and then the second
player will be the the program and the
program itself so here we have a simple
exchange so well at the beginning its is
just a handshake so basically the these
moves mean that we have arrived at at a
value and the evaluation was successful
so that's what star means and then they
devalue the function is being used so
here the environment calls it on that
reference name and one such that the
currently five is sorted this reference
and then as an outcome we get false and
then the the value does not change
because this term does not do anything
to the reference status that is that
this past so then the environment can
call the function again perhaps on some
different name well we're 15 is stalled
and maybe in the process the environment
also wants to modify the content of the
previous name but in any case the answer
will be false and then well this door
will will be will be the same so if we
run these terms through the game
semantics engine turns out that in both
cases we obtain the same set of plays
and we can conclude that these terms are
equivalent so you would like to automate
this process and be able to well
basically construct a tool that take
these terms and besides these things
for us so next I'm going to start
talking about automata and the focus
will be on on equivalence problems but
I'm going to start with emptiness and
reach ability because in many cases
equivalence can be reduced to these
problems so these are the happy cases
and otherwise i'll talk about its
equivalents problems such as language
equivalents or by similarity testing so
another experience two kinds of automata
turn out to be suitable for representing
the game semantically notations of terms
so of course there is a point where we
cannot really hope to decide equivalence
it gets undecidable but then the cases
where we could show equivalence
decidable these are these will be the
ultimate are and thats that will
generate these that will be used to
underpin the decision procedures so
register tow mater and then i'm going to
extend them slightly to do food down
register automata so register automata
is there is a modern name for a model
gold finite memory automaton introduced
by Kaminsky in France's and then a more
modern presentation was used by Evan
genetic in Vienna they are quite simple
so they have finitely many states and in
addition they have a fixed set of
registers and are in my case and then
these registers can store elements of
the infinite alphabet and we assume that
different names have to be stored in
different in different places in the
registers the transitions are of the
following shapes and we can play a name
that is already in a register and by the
way the the letters that's
that are being read by these automata
and our pears and so the first component
is a tag taken from a finite alphabet as
some kind of Phi Knights template and
then the second element is a name drawn
from the infinite alphabet I so
languages based on letters of this kind
are called data beta languages ok so in
the register tomorrow we can have
transitions that play names that are
already in registers and then there are
also transitions that allow us to play
names that are fresh that's do not occur
in the register and after the transition
they will be they will be moved to
register I I so this transition could be
viewed as name generation we are
generating something that that's not
present in registers and this is called
local freshness as one can also try to
strengthen the models with global
freshness were we require that this name
be completely fresh for the whole
computation but let me skip add this
feature in my talk because actually the
complexity theoretical results are the
same if we if we add global freshness to
to the picture ok so these models they
are based on on on names and they have
some nice properties related to well
symmetry and invariance so first of all
if we have a run and then if we take a
permutation on our names permutation on
this infinite set of elements well then
we can construct another run so runs are
invariant and then because we only have
a fixed number of registers or in my
case these machines cannot really
distinguish more than r plus 1 names so
what do I mean by this and so here's
here's the statement so whenever we have
a run that reaches a state it is
possible to find another run that
reaches the same state but a run which
only uses
r plus 1 letters right so this is
because well D automaton can only
remember our names so if it needs a
fresh one we can always supply whether
the remaining one from the set of r plus
1 names and we can the automaton can can
still proceed and reach the desired
state so this this this property
actually gives a obvious reduction to
the world of finite alphabets which
allows us to decide the emptiness
problem in in in this setting so well we
can reduce it to reach ability in
directed graphs and hence the the
problem so of course one would like to
solve other problems notably the
equivalence problem but then
difficulties with that in the general
model and so ideally we would like to
find that that's these the languages
accepted such automata are closed under
complementation and union and so on
which would allow us to reduce inclusion
and equivalents to mutability which we
know is decidable but this is not what
happens in this in this model so even
though the languages are closed on the
union and intersection they are not
closed under complementation and
actually a one can show as was done in a
paper by never Enchantix invr new that's
the inclusion problem 44 these automata
is undecidable so actually they're not
not only inclusion but also equivalence
and universality ok so that's bad news
but the Sun decidability results depend
on non determinism and in the
deterministic case one can one can
recover the the properties I I would
like to I would like to have because
complementation can still be can still
be performed
and the deterministic case inclusion and
equivalents are decidable and while the
obvious bound sets that one can extract
from this reduction to finite alphabet
is that Lardis bounds p space and so
these are these are the obvious balance
so it's a bit less obvious to show that
actually inclusion is pspace complete
and we have managed to come to obtain
this nice result saying that equivalence
of deterministic register hamata is
actually solvable NP rather than p space
and so in order to arrive at this
results we had to delve into by
similarity and so by similarity again is
decidable and the decidability can be
shown by a well by the same reduction to
finite alphabet so we can blow up the
automaton 2nite alphabet but then this
reduction is costly least an exponential
blow-up so the obvious upper bound for
by similarity is exponential time but
then thanks to group theoretic results
and structure of the problem we have
managed to reduce it from X time to to
to NP so next let let let me tell you a
bit more about by similarity testing and
in this setting so that they can create
problem right given two configurations
we would like to decide whether they are
by similar and it's quite easy to see
that's and well that's in order to if
configurations are by similar all all
that matters is is is the relationship
between names that are in one set of
registers and the names inside
the other set of registers so by
similarity can be accounted for in a
symbolic way where we are actually
talking about but it's a molarity of
states up to a permutation although it's
not a permutations a partial permutation
because these the contents of these
registers do not do not have to match so
we have well defined a suitable and
notion of symbolic by similarity that
captures this problem and we looked at
the structural properties of that
concept which turned out quite first of
all because we managed to get better
complexity bands there are some crucial
properties of disembodied by similarity
it's closed on the composition so this
is the composition of off partial
permutations it is also a monotone in
this sense so if two states are by
similar under the assumption that the
names match according to Sigma it turns
out that if we have if we take a bigger
matching then it will also be by similar
so the this this symbolic concept
behaves well with respect to and
composition and more monotonicity
actually in order to find them a proof
of membership in P we would like to use
these facts to find sir well small
generating and sets so this this
generation will be with respect to
composition but then we also we are also
going to take advantage of this
monotonicity and it's really less
trivial to see how to do that because we
cannot really intersect to two partial
and do partial permutations right in
order to investigate the problem find
these these small generating sets well
we looked at the set of partial
permutations and that make the same
state by similar to this thesis is the
set off of partial auto
symmetries and it turned out that this
set has a very nice structure so the
property related to to generating things
in partial permutations are not good
enough to give the results that we are
after so while we had to try to observe
a bit more about their set and when this
period that turned out fruit quality to
have a look at kinds of partial
identities that underpinned by
similarity and right few minute and so
writer so thanks to investigations about
these partial symmetries we managed to
identify a group that's under pins and
this sad even though this is a set of
partial of parrot Alzheimer patients so
if we can't down and this set to if we
can do by similarity to has living in
this set then we get a group and then we
can try to use results from group theory
to to investigate then this process so
this is the first result that turns are
useful as it is known that if we take a
symmetric group then strict chains of
subgroups length linea in in in r where
r is the number of elements and so why
is this result important well it is
known that by similarity can be obtained
in an iterative way by investigating
what happens after zero steps one step
two steps and so on and it turns out
that in our setting this well is the
this this process of zooming in on and
the largest by similarity can be linked
to to the shrinkage of subgroups I so
thanks to the result basically we can
conclude that this this chain of
relations will stabilize
after poor normally many steps so if we
know that by similarity can be obtained
by investigating polynomial e relations
of but normally many relations of this
kind it's easy to see that we can decide
it in alternating p time and well this
is this is pspace so this already gives
us something better than the next time
which which was the obvious band as
there's another group result in group
theory that stands out helpful so this
result says that every subgroup of a
symmetric group over our elements has at
most sir well this linear number of
generators cater for for each group sets
underpinned steez by similarity
relations that we were investigating we
can find linearly many generators okay
but this is the this does not
automatically lead to an MP algorithm
because these groups were just related
to symmetries of the same state so they
were they were auto symmetries whereas
we also need to cover situations where
we have different states but fortunately
thanks to compositionality there's this
this this can be done and we can show
that it suffices to provide just one
witness if these two states are related
by some partial sanitation so on the
whole can conclude that's the symbolic
by similarity has a generating set of
polynomial size and which means well we
can now guess it and what's more we can
check that this is indeed a generating
set of over by simulation relation using
well this third results from group
theory which says the group membership
testing it can be done in in polynomial
time so overall we can conclude that by
similarity testing for register tamata
and is in NP and we do not have matching
a lower bound which is intriguing as now
all these techniques can be put to use
and in order to share that's the
equivalent of
termina stick register da Matta is in p
why is why is that so in this NP result
we have to guess and this generating set
and but for deterministic registered how
matter we can actually generate it and
this is a modification of them known
algorithm for deterministic finite
automata due to hopcroft ends an end and
car okay so these were registered to
matter which turned out something about
the containment of deterministically
odometer yes as several slides back
it'sit's decidable and pspace complete
okay so here we have a situation where
where the complexities are different
which which doesn't have happened very
very often about the one that heavy NP
upper bound is it conceivable it's in NP
yeah we haven't managed to make any
progress on this it seems to us this
might be related to to graph isomorphism
we looked at NC yeah we yeah we don't
have a good guest good BMP even we okay
so a second class of automata that
turned are useful for representing these
game semantic models are pushed down
register Thomas are they extend register
tomorrow with a with a with a stack so
again they operate over infant alphabets
and and one would like to reduce the
emptiness problem to the finite world
again but now it's not so clear how many
letters are needed to do that because
stack is the stack is potentially
unbounded so the previous results saying
that r plus 1 elements suffice is not
good searching in Kaminsky who
introduced these machines and they did
show and decide ability of emptiness but
the proof went through several stages
actually the number of letters that is
needed to perform the reduction was was
lost somewhere and and later on other
authors noted that it's not apparent
have to determine the number from the
definition of the automata so we we made
progress on this question attend
that the magic number is is three times
the number of registers so I don't have
enough time to explain this but this
result immediately implies that reach
ability and push down register automatic
is decidable and and the problem can be
the problem is in exponential time so in
contrast when one looks at by similarity
it turns out to be undecidable which is
perhaps a quite a disappointment because
in the finite world although it was hard
it was known to be decidable so then
we'll in order to to a bit more about
stacks we also looked at high order
cruise down automata these are a tow
mater that have stacks of stacks and so
on and so these automata are also
undecidable in indy with over day
infinite and I so using these automata
and actually these these variations
where the global freshness capable of
generating fully fresh elements well we
show the number of decidability results
for these languages fragment of ml and
and java and HD for in some cases we
constructed constructed tools that can
decide equivalents and they're fully
fully automated fashion okay thanks yes
so actually this this this is my last
slide and so I talked about register
tomorrow and push down register
automaton in the context of modeling
this generative computation and so
within semantics automata over internet
alphabets also emerged for a different
reason and this is to model hi all the
computation so if we look at this type
saying okay so it's a nice first order
type seems quite simple but actually if
it generates lots of complicated
interactions because if we apply terms
of this type two arguments we are going
to get functions
and each of these functions can be
called again so so this phenomenon could
be captured with this pattern so so this
is just a handshake but here we are
applying the term of this kind once you
apply it twice and then again so here we
had three applications each of them led
to a function of type unit aero unit and
finally we may wish to call one of these
functions again so in order to call them
we need to indicate which one and do
want to call is it the first one second
one all the third one and in-game
semantics this is done with pointers as
now if if one wants to model this in an
auto automata theoretically it makes
sense to use to use names to indicate at
which copy we actually want to point so
for instance because here want to point
at that occurrence we would use the same
names to account for for this situation
so the the data words that corresponds
to this scenario looks like this so in
this context different classes of
automata over in a photographer bed and
are useful and these are variations of
the class memory ultimate are due to
your account and and and and and fantic
so they have a completely different
flavor and the decision problems are
related to problems on petry nets
actually extensions of patterning nets
such as nasty Petra nested Petra nets
and variants that use branching so
actually in this area the modeling of
high-order computation certain
equivalence problems that arise from
work on high order programs can be shown
to be equivalent to open problems in
this area of for instance branching
branching petri nets and this is my last
slide thank you very much
question
yes they're gaining semantics problems
you also have trees pop up and so and I
mean they're not arising explicitly but
actually in this work we were able to
identify a fragment that was equivalent
of branching patroness so in in in in
this way trees arise implicitly okay
let's hang country again